i'd like to
read a poem
if i may sure
and this is um i i guess from your from
i mean i can't even stop you without
violating quarantine you're trying
isolation to come in here um
so this is in the sun uh this
magazine which is which we subscribe to
which i i like a lot um
from the october 2021 issue and um
i'll just read this without comment
first and then i'll comment afterwards
by a woman named allison luderman it's
called a few days after my first vaccine
walking by the end this is the october
2021 issue so we know what vaccine she
is referring to
a few days after my first vaccine
walking by the lake i lose an earring
and don't even notice it at first
overwhelmed as i am by the strangeness
of everything
blocks later my hand reaches up to feel
that slight absence in one ear
so then i have to retrace my steps as
they say to do
past the guy jogging with his mask pull
down and the hijab wearing stroller
pushing young mother in stylish jeans
and the homeless man emerging from his
tent on the banks of our urban oasis
bearing a boom box on one shoulder
and that's where i spot it lying on the
sidewalk miraculously untrampled small
precious found thing a turquoise oval
encircled with rows of beads given to me
with love by someone i haven't hugged in
more than a year
tiny rescue from the sea of loss just as
we seem to have found a raft to grab
onto in the wake of a shipwreck so vast
we cannot yet imagine the end of it
i was struck by this poem
i've read it several times now
because i think it finally gave me some
insight that i've been looking for
into the mindset of the people who
really believed and many of whom still
believe
that
the vaccines are going to be our
salvation
this is this this tells us that the last
lines
about the earring but we know what she's
talking about tiny rescue from the sea
of lost just as we seem to have found a
raft to grab onto in the wake of a
shipwreck so vast we cannot yet imagine
the end of it
the vaccines are around the vaccines
have been promoted by these same health
officials who have had incoherent after
incoherent damaging after damaging
recommendation and
and uh and
mandate in many cases
that that come down on us with regard to
this thing and they are the ones who
successfully sold to many many people
the idea that there is one and only one
solution for you
it will be the vaccine that is the only
thing that will help you these are the
same people who will not talk about
repurposed drugs they will not talk
about vitamin d they will not talk about
the value and virtue and wisdom and
health of moving your body and losing
weight and eating real food they will
not talk about any of those things the
only thing they talk about is
the vaccine and so in a honestly pretty
hippy crunchy liberal dippy magazine
like the sun which i love
we have a poem that ends just as we seem
to have found a raft to grab onto
no these vaccines aren't that they're
not that and every passing week assures
us that that's not the case so
how do we
how do we talk to the people who still
think that they're the raft
and that those of us who didn't grab
onto the raft
are not actually sinking them
so
the
i'm struck frequently you know you
mentioned at the beginning of the
podcast that the first tripwire we hit
was the lab leak i don't actually feel
that it was a tripwire because
you know i think of them actually as
third rails
and that one
we touched it
and
i think people were already clear enough
that something about the story of the
origin of this virus was uh
phony enough
that um
we didn't suffer the same fate as
discussing early treatment i think
you're misremembering how hard it was
for the first year actually
um
that maybe let's let's put it aside
though nonetheless being steeped in the
question of lab leak and then finding
ourselves with an appalling cartoonish
upside down public health response being
managed by
who
being managed by
the dude who circumvented the law
in order to make gain of function
research that he wanted done
moved to china
so that the congress's ability to
prevent gain of function research from
being done explicitly because it could
cause a very serious pandemic
he wanted to override that so
once we are being fed
i mean if that was ineptitude fine but
the point is is that not sufficient
ineptitude that this person couldn't
possibly be put in charge of dealing
with the pandemic right and having
failed to deal with the pandemic
couldn't possibly be left in charge and
certainly that same person who overrode
the ban on gain of function research and
offshored it
to china that that guy couldn't possibly
be the one to decide whether we should
just double down on the same vaccines in
light of omicron or maybe switch gears
why is that same guy in charge of the
question right that should be on
everybody's mind this is a path charge
not just of the question with regard to
the vaccines but
the only two possible drugs that have
been considered which turn out to be
both ineffective and toxic
um are the ones that are produced by the
profit-making entities as well right and
i would just add to that list of
amazing anomalies you know how many
times were we shouted out about the
uh supposed failure of uh randomized
controlled trials uh as evidence for
drugs that uh in a clinical setting
clearly
work but you know we have a randomized
controlled trial that that says
fluvoxamine works extremely well and
it's not like that has been rushed to
the forefront of the standard of care so
we have a
an incoherence right we had to do
everything to rush these vaccines to
market in a single year and it is an
impressive feat to have done it
irrespective of whether or not the
vaccines
are something that should be
contemplated by
people but nonetheless we were in this
incredible rush to get a vaccine out the
door and now it's been a year and we're
suck we're stuck with the same
vaccine it hasn't even been updated with
respect to antigen right we were in such
a rush we're now rushing with the
malnupiravir right
but we have a drug that has passed
randomized controlled trial appears to
have a very good effect and there
doesn't seem to be any movement on it at
all what is this this is all true but i
think we're talking across purposes and
i think maybe you and i are just in
different places with regard to what is
gripping us most at the moment about the
other absurdity of the moment that we're
living in
and i for for months now really have
been trying to figure out what's in the
heads of the
of just the people
who are going along with this and
helping making helping make these
policies these insane policies stick and
persist
and this poem i feel like gave me some
insight and what i don't know is
you know how
how to reach
such people you know you and i have both
talked about
things that we do you know eavesdropping
when we're out not that that's going to
happen for a few days here but um or you
know just
raising anything that sounds like
non-narrative non not on narrative
doubts
in casual interchanges and being not at
this point surprised by the vast
majority of people who immediately grasp
onto that and go like oh yes yes i don't
see it the way i'm being told i see it
right
and i mean i had an interchange this
week with a woman
who i do know in passing
but who i thought was totally on board
who just got boosted
recently and is done
she is
done
the side effects she's experiencing
the fear now of what she has done to
herself and the fights that she is
having with family and friends over her
refusal to engage in the cognitive
dissonance anymore
it's extraordinary this reflects what a
lot of people are going through but how
you know how
how to be open
and honest and honorable enough
to reach more to reach the people who
would write a poem
that seems so earnest
and has so misplaced its faith in that
raft the vaccine is these vaccines are
no right
well but i think in some sense it's the
same thing right
i'm frequently asked to isolate the
issues from each other all right let's
leave aside the issue of of repurposed
drugs let's talk about the vaccines and
the answer is you can't actually
separate those because the whole
argument in favor of taking a vaccine
this novel
and applying it so broadly is that we
didn't have a choice and to the extent
that we did have a choice and that
choice was driven off the map first in
order to make the argument that well
okay it's novel but we don't really have
a choice the point is those are two
sides of the same coin and so the sense
that the person who sees the vaccines as
the raft
is conveying is a sense that was
cultivated for them it's not a natural
conclusion
right we would be somewhere very
different if doctors had been allowed to
do their thing which some great doctors
did right
doctors are supposed to be scientists
when they have an emergent condition
they are supposed to say well here are
the symptoms and this is what i think it
implies about what's taking place inside
of this person and here are some
compounds that have this and that effect
and i'm going to try them
and they are supposed to learn and then
they are supposed to talk to each other
and that process is supposed to make
doctors better and better at treating
the disease and what we did instead was
we had some top-down bureaucratic thing
telling doctors what they were allowed
to think what they were allowed to try
what they were allowed to discuss it has
literally removed licenses it has fired
people who concluded things that were
contrary to the public health authority
and it has created
an environment in which basically you
have two choices you either embrace the
advice of a public health authority that
is clearly mad
or you're on your own and
neither of those are good choices
but it is time that we the public i mean
in some sense aren't we stuck
when you and i were kids
the idea of entheogens right these were
very controversial and the idea that a
person might actually have the right to
ingest a mushroom that would alter the
way they saw the world that was not
understood to be a right by most people
and some of us said well what is the
basis on which a government tells you
you can't alter your thinking by eating
a mushroom that does not appear to be
toxic right why does the government get
to do that and of course you know in
2020 2021 2022 we're waking up to the
fact that maybe the government doesn't
have that right and in fact
there are therapeutic benefits to these
things but why is this situation any
different right you've got a variant out
there
it is not safe
but you are being offered other
alternatives that aren't safe
you're being offered vaccines that
aren't safe and you're being offered
offered the gamble that you will face
future variants that are even much less
safe do you not have a right to decide
for yourself that actually you know what
given everything i know about this
disease and given what i know about the
hazard of omicron that i'm better off
contracting it and if you're really in
good shape you can actually manage the
disease with many of the tools that the
renegade doctors have discovered works
right are you not entitled to do that in
consultation with your doctor and if not
why not
[Music]